- "I should be
Rookie of the Year because..."
- I should be
a Rookie of the Year because...
- [Announcer:] Herro driving.
Goes to the left hand
and gets it to go!
[Cheering]
- There is this narrative
around Jimmy
that he is, like,
some bad teammate.
- Those people just don't know
much about basketball.
- [Announcer:]
Butler out to Herro for three.
Yes!
[Cheering]
- I gotta ask you
your top five Kentucky Wildcats.
- Oh. Can I say myself?
♪♪♪
This is Tyler Herro
from the University of Kentucky,
a rookie for the Miami Heat.
And we're taking it there
in Miami with Taylor Rooks.
♪♪♪
Checkin' in from Miami
with the rook,
with Taylor Rooks.
Ya dig?
- OK. OK.
You were thinkin' about that?
[Both laughing]
♪♪♪
How wild is it
that you live in Miami?
- Yeah, that is wild.
I love it, though.
Look at this.
- I know, the skyline.
The thing that's crazy, though,
is even just, like, being
around you, you fit Miami.
Do you feel that way?
- Everybody says that.
That doesn't make sense.
How do you fit Miami?
- [Taylor Rooks:] It's cuz
you have the chill, like,
laid-back Miami vibe.
♪♪♪
- [Laughing]
♪♪
- I know you can't swim.
- Oh, my God.
- All right.
- [Laughing]
So that's for you.
This@
- I gotta put this on?
- [Taylor:] No, you don't,
but, you know.
- [Tyler Herro:] All right.
- Just until you
take your swimming lessons.
- I do need this.
- That's for you.
- Thank you.
- How did it end up
that you can't swim?
- I used to take
swimming lessons,
but I never would go.
- OK.
- Cuz I never felt like
I needed to learn how to swim.
You gonna teach me?
- I can teach you.
I'm a great swimmer.
Are you@ But o@
- Jump in.
- [Taylor:] Only if you wa@
You know I'm not messin' up
my hair.
♪♪♪
It's insane
because you just turned 20.
And, look,
you just got out of your teens.
- [Chuckling]
- OK?
I'm not trying to "son" you
or anything. [Laughing]
- I'm grown.
- Yeah, you're grown. 20.
- Yeah.
- [Taylor:] I feel you.
- Grown 20.
- [Taylor:]
But you're 20 years old,
and, like, this is what you do.
- [Chuckling] Yeah.
- Like, this is your life,
living in Miami.
- [Tyler:] Mmhmm.
- Being in the NBA.
Do you ever feel like
life moved really quickly?
- I think going to Kentucky made
it move that@ how fast it did.
That's what@
how like Coach Cal
sets his players up for success
with the one-year program,
getting out,
and going one and done
- Yeah.
- straight to the NBA.
I knew if I did my@ what I was
supposed to at Kentucky
that it was gonna end up
moving fast.
- You know what I was doing
when I was 20?
I was, like, in
- [Tyler:] What's that?
- a little apartment in
Champaign, Illinois, in college,
- [Laughing]
- eating ramen noodles.
- Well, look at you now.
-Yeah. But, like, at 20.
I can't imagine all the things,
like, available to you.
- Everybody has their own path.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- Different, different ways of
getting where they want to go.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- Happens quicker
for other people.
- [Announcer:] That's Herro.
That's good!
- [Announcer:]
A triple for Tyler Herro.
- [Taylor:] OK.
Complete this sentence.
"I should be Rookie of the Year
because..."
- I should be
a Rookie of the Year because...
look at my numbers.
I've missed a couple games,
but I feel like
I've impacted the game a lot,
and I'm also the youngest guy,
and that's a conversation.
- All right,
so, with the Heat this year,
you're in a locker room that has
Jimmy Butler.
You got Bam.
- [Tyler:] Jimmy Buckets!
- [Taylor:] You've got
another talented player
in Kendrick Nunn.
What are the dynamics like?
- Well, we all bring, like,
our own personality
to the locker room,
and then we all bring
our own skill set to the court,
so we all fit
and jell well together.
I couldn't ask for a better
locker room for my rookie year.
- What personality
does Jimmy bring?
♪♪♪
- [Tyler:] Jimmy's like the
leader, the head of the snake.
At the same time,
he's, like, funny.
Like, he crack jokes.
He's funny. He's hysterical.
- What personality
does Bam bring?
- [Tyler:]
Bam's like the laid-back leader
who's just, like, a vet,
but he's still young,
so it's like,
- Mm.
- like, he defines
the difference between the two.
- What personality does
Kendrick bring?
- He's that rookie
who doesn't talk much.
I only hear him talk when we
hang out away from the court.
- It seems like you and Jimmy
have become, like, super close.
How has that relationship
blossomed?
- It started in the summer
when I went to Chicago
to work out with him,
and then I'd be at his house
all the time for, like,
and we'd just hang out, so.
- [Taylor:] Mmhmm.
- He's like a big brother to me.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
You know,
it's weird because, you know,
Jimmy has been on my show.
I like Jimmy a lot.
There's this narrative
around Jimmy
that he is, like,
some bad teammate.
- Yeah.
- What would you say to people
that believe that to be true?
- [Tyler:] I think what we've
done so far just alone this year
and what he's done,
he should have been a, I think,
a, an All-Star starter.
Those people just don't know
much about basketball.
Like, he@ he just hates
to lose. He loves to win.
And I think that's where him
and some players
on his previous teams@
there was a gap in there.
♪♪♪
Checkin' in.
- [Taylor:] Yeah!
[Laughing]
♪♪♪
- Oh, there's some, there's some
dolphins right here, yo.
- Oh, my goodness!
- Do you see?
- There's a dolphin!
[Gasping]
- [Tyler:] Ooh!
What's the dolphin noise?
Arr, arr.
- Aren't those seals?
- [Offscreen:] Sounds like
"Eeeeeh!"
- [Laughing]
Those are seals, Tyler.
[All laughing]
- [Offscreen:] He said,
"Arr, arr!"
- He said, "Arr, arr."
[All laughing]
- [Offscreen:]
These are dolphins?
- [Taylor:]
Please tell me someone got that.
- [Laughing]
- [Offscreen:] We got it.
♪♪♪
- [Taylor:]
I was watching that interview
with you, Jimmy and Bam.
- [Tyler:] Mmhmm.
- And when
they were talking about players
that you were like,
every player they named
was white.
- [Tyler:] Yeah.
- And you were like,
"OK, you can't just compare me
to other white players."
- [Chuckling] Yeah.
- [Taylor:] But one thing
that's interesting about you
is I don't think
you're viewed in the NBA
as, like, the token white guy.
- Yeah.
- You're just
a part of the team.
- Yeah.
- But I think, for most players,
it's hard to kind of overcome
that label.
- For most white players,
you're saying?
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- Yeah, I agree.
I think that's why who I am.
I think you just gotta.
Like, as a little kid, I was
taught to just be different.
- Mmhmm.
- If I wanted to get to the NBA
and get to my dreams,
I had to be different.
- [Taylor:] Your Twitter name
is raf_tyler.
- [Chuckling] Yeah.
- [Taylor:] What, what does
"raf" stand for?
Enlighten me.
- It stands for
"rich and famous."
- [Taylor:] Oh, OK.
- [Tyler:] But I did that
before I got to the NBA.
- So you were rich and famous
before you got to the NBA.
[Laughing]
- Yeah, in, like, sixth grade.
- So, you've always had
this persona about you@
the type of persona that would
say they're rich and famous
in the sixth grade.
[Laughing]
- [Laughing]
I guess.
- How would you describe your
personality and that persona?
- My personality@
I would say I'm confident.
- OK.
- I'm very confident.
I'm outgoing. I don't know.
- OK.
- I can talk to
pretty much anybody.
- OK.
- But I'm, like, low-key.
So, like, I don't, I don't like
talking to just anybody,
but I will.
- Every single person in the NBA
that I would ask about you,
they all used the same word,
which was "swaggy."
- [Laughing]
- Where does the swag come from?
- [Tyler:] I, like,
developed it on my own, I guess.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- [Tyler:] Over time,
got my swag together, I guess.
[Laughing]
- And then, today,
you were trying to be
like me with the shoes.
- [Tyler:] Yeah.
You were trying to be like me.
- No, you were trying
to copy my shoes.
- No, you're definitely
trying to be like me.
- [Taylor:] So I provided
the swag today.
- You seen all my Instagram pics
with all of my shoes.
- So you always [laughing]
- Now you wanna be like me.
- [Laughing]
- That's crazy.
♪♪♪
You know I, I rap too?
I'm a rapper.
- [Taylor:] You got music?
- [Tyler:] Yeah, me and K-Nunn.
- [Taylor:]
You really have a mix-tape?
- [Tyler, chuckling]:
Me and him, yeah.
This our songs right here.
We got this one.
- What?
- We got this one.
- OK,
you have to play one for me.
- [Tyler:] OK.
- This one.
- [Tyler:]♪♪♪ Come to Miami,
we ride on a yacht ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ These diamonds, they
dancing, they cost me a lot ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ The paint's blue tone.
It's wet like a mop ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Christian Dior@
I drip to my socks ♪♪♪
- [Laughing]
That was actually pretty good.
You have a little flow to you.
[Both laughing]
- Oh, you thought I was playing.
- I did.
I was like, "He bullshitting."
[Both laughing]
- Oh, I'm good.
- I'm dead.
♪♪♪
All right, Tyler,
that is enough yacht for me.
Let's get in the car
and take you home.
OK, so, before we go,
I had a friend of mine
make a video for you
that I think you might like.
OK?
- [Dwyane Wade:]
Yo, Taylor. What up?
"T," man, just say from a former
Miami Heat player, man,
I just want to say
how proud I am of you
and how you represent yourself,
killer.
So, man, keep doing what you do.
You know how to play
this game of basketball.
Um, you know,
keep making us proud, man,
and especially the way you swag
when you walk into that arena,
um, keep doing it, brother,
aight?
Love.
- That's dope.
- [Taylor:] D-Wade.
- [Tyler:] That's dope.
- What's it like hearing that?
- He's a legend in Miami.
So hearing that from him,
he someone that I look up to
and want to follow
in his footsteps.
That means a lot.
- You were genuinely surprised
when you saw that video.
- Yeah, I was. I didn't think
it was gonna be him at all.
That was, that was fire.
- OK, so, just kind of off GP,
Dwyane Wade has to be in there.
But give me your top five
Miami Heat players.
- [Tyler:] D-Wade.
LeBron.
Uh, Chris Bosh.
Uh, Shaq.
And I'll go with J-Will.
- [Taylor:] OK. I like that.
- [Tyler:] "White Chocolate."
- [Taylor:] White Chocolate?
- [Tyler:] Yeah.
- Now I gotta ask you
your top five Kentucky Wildcats.
- Oh! Can I say myself?
- [Taylor:] You can.
You must say yourself.
- All right. So, me.
I'll go John Wall,
Anthony Davis.
[Clearing throat]
D-Book
and Rex Chapman.
- [Taylor:] OK.
- [Tyler:] A little throwback.
Do you know who that is?
- [Taylor:] A strong list. I do.
- All right.
- That's my job
to know who that is.
- All right, bet.
- [Laughing]
Now, allegedly,
you are this, like,
swaggy guy who can dress well.
- [Chuckling] My God.
- So I will show you some photos
of your fellow rookies
and their outfits
- All right, all right.
- and you're gonna grade them
for me, OK?
- [Tyler:] All right.
- Like, A, B, C, D, F.
- All right, talk to me.
- OK. First up: Zion.
- [Tyler:] I'd say that's a@
that's a C.
- [Taylor:]
Yeah, it's a little C.
- [Tyler:]
It's a regular fit.
- [Laughing]
He didn't really pop out?
- Yeah, he didn't pop out.
- [Taylor:] Got Sekou
with the leopard blazer.
- [Tyler:] That's a C.
He should have
did leopard pants too.
- You would've gone
full leopard?
- Yeah.
- OK.
Darius?
- [Tyler, chuckling:] I'm gonna
give him an A-plus on that,
just cuz he...
- [Taylor:] Really?
- [Tyler:] How many people
would wear that?
- The confidence it took
to wear it.
- Yeah.
My man, that's nice.
- And he walked in there
real confident too.
I remember watching
the tunnel walk, like@
He was@
- Yeah, I seen that.
- [Taylor:] Yeah.
- That was nice.
- [Taylor:] OK.
- That's how he looks.
- So my one takeaway from
spending this off-day with you
is I hope you realize
how lucky you are
that you live
on the water in Miami.
[Chuckling]
- Mmhmm, I'm blessed.
- Yes. You really are.
Thank you so much
for being on the show.
- [Tyler:]
I appreciate you having me.
- Yeah.
- [Tyler:] It was a great time.
Great, great day, off-day
on the boat.
I appreciate it.
- Yeah.
Have a great season.
- Thank you.
- All right, I'll see you.
- I'll see you too.
♪♪♪